[Musique]
les touristes se font attendre normandie
mais la normandie peut compter sur un an
ba
leur céleste l'enfant du pays thomas
pesquet l'astronaute qui est arrivé
samedi dans la station spatiale
internationale à vous le voyez publié
son premier cliché et il a choisi sa
région la normandie avec autant sur le
cliché on aperçoit le havre et surtout
rouen la ville où il est né
cette photo de la terre est la première
d'une longue série promet l'astronaute
là thomas pesquet à partager une photo
de ce qu'il appelle les toilettes dans
la lah
la twingo qui est dans la capsule et qui
l'a mené vers liège ça hyper intrigué
tous les internautes c'est l'une de ces
photos que fait le plus réagir
en gros il disait que la vue était
imprenable lemay qui avait juste un
simple rideau et puis
ça ce sont les toilettes de cette
capsule
chanter qu'est ce qu'on sait
au fond de cette boîte heures
jean teulé samedi
[Musique]
en tous cas la pierre a l'air très
friable ouais du coup tu oublieras pas
de toiles et de coop terre à la fois des
digues d'accord merci dans la navette
spatiale pour bien centré sur les
toilettes
il ya une caméra au sol dans ce moteur
qui filme l'anus pour apprendre à bien
centré à le siège soit vous êtes et des
petits cette technique
ah oui c'est technique mais c'est
important je trouve ça incroyable de
voter avec daniel serrés entre les ouf
du coup ça me perturbe un peu la voix
qui tremble je les mains qui tremblent
je vais je tombais amoureuse lui je
crois c'est bon je ne cours pas march
concourt on réfléchit pas si j'ai bien
compris là c'est un festin et j'adore
l'espace cassin et spatiales ah d'accord
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait croire
parce que souvent d'une image que de la
nourriture lyophilisée beaucoup de gens
qui disent ah bah non pas du tout il ya
des conserves
il ya effectivement des cacahuètes ce
genre de choses mais ils mangent quand
même des fruits frais à nouveau dans un
temps de 2 à dents à chaque
ravitaillement pour le bien du corps
mais aussi pour le bien de l'esprit il
ya en effet un astronaute dont j'ai
oublié non un américain qui s'ébat lui
en nourriture ses commandes et des
saucisses et il est sorti des toilettes
en lâchant cette saucisse l'année en
faisant au pardon et pendant deux
minutes tout le monde a cru qu'il avait
perdu un élément de déposer et il l'a
attrapé il l'a croqué tous été terrifiée
parce qu'il n'a pas eu tant de savoir ce
que c'était donc c'était une bonne
blague d'astronautes comment on passe de
cette préparation qu'on fait pour les
repas qu'on va manger à bord vous êtes à
des repas dans la fusée ça change des
choses ou pas faut pas que ça soit trop
liquide sinon ça goûte il faut pas que
ça se faut que ça soit pas tous puissent
prendre et que ce soit consistant dont
ça se mange à la cuillère exactement
qu'est ce qu'ils fument comme ça
mais non je viens de brûler seuls dégâts
bravo moins bien ouej je viens de cramer
le sol
ça va ajouter un petit goût de fumé
cramer un sympa des doses mais pas de
passion dans les différents centres de
vaccination en france on estime à plus
de 280 mille le nombre de créneaux
disponibles selon l'application vite ma
dose avec une stratégie vaccinale par
tranche d'âge ce sont les personnes de
plus de 55 ans qui ont la priorité pour
le ministre de la santé
pas question pour le moment d'ouvrir la
vaccination un public plus jeune
aux etats unis charles un gouverneur qui
offre 100 dollars aux jeunes qui
acceptent de se faire vacciner ça se
passe en virginie occidentale où
l'épidémie ne faiblit pas pourtant les
doses de vaccins sont disponibles mais
les moins de 35 ans traîne des pieds
alors pour les motiver le gouverneur
vient d'annoncer qu'il allait leur
offrir des bons d'une valeur de 100 $
il s'agit de bons du trésor une sorte d'
épargne qu'il devra permettre de motiver
ces jeunes j'ai réussi durant les trois
jours de consultations à faire si doses
de vaccin toutes les autres personnes
ont refusé le vaccin
voilà personne n'en veut j'ai donc ici
dans la main sans doute un des outils
thérapeutiques les plus efficaces contre
les virus
ce vaccin est à présent périmés je suis
obligé de le jeter et plus insolite
encore dans l'état de new york pour
fêter la légalisation de la marijuana
des militants ont lancé la semaine
dernière une opération consistant à
offrir de l'herbe aux jeunes vacciner un
joint de contrats vaccin
pour moi
ça va
symonds suspendu dans les 5 mètres de
hauteur entre deux bâtiments vue
exceptionnelle pour les premiers nageurs
qui ont pu accéder avancement
l'inauguration aura lieu courant mai
vous le voyez pour de 25 mètres
entièrement en verre une première
mondiale selon le constructeur
alors si vous voulez y aller donc il
faudra attendre un peu pour l'instant
seuls les habitants de ces résidences
luxueuses pour en bénéficier
moi je pars du principe que soit un show
était moche soit à froid et elles et
veulent donc je suis peut être belle
avec du show non à mon nom je vais
entrer chez elle ça n'existe pas
vraiment mon cerveau alors j'aime
beaucoup le
jean damien devisme par entame ses films
en fait il ya un trou de dans madame à
ça c'est pas chic
il ya un trou dedans ouais je me permets
alors parfois ce n'est pas le jean que
je vous ai donné je ne vends pas cette
marque
je pense que c'est votre jeu que j'ai
mis ça me plaisanterie un cas ce sont
les sommes se croyable écoute c'est vrai
que tant citron et dit cole la culotte
lors
shubi c'est un métier de mecs en réalité
et aux meules et nana c'est très
compliqué parce qu'une femme n'a pas le
droit de vieillir après 40 ans elle est
éjecté moi je le vois partout quoi donc
moi je m'accroche parce que je trouve ça
totalement injuste et que et que les
femmes ont leur place mais alors elle
continue quand même jane birkin chante
c'est vrai mais dans wii mais oui
d'accord allez si vous regardez bien on
les passe pas mal un beau travail
allez courage et fortes sommes pas si tu
viens clair la radio vous voulez radio
ces femmes sont exclues
je ne comprends pas pourquoi on ne passe
pas alors bah si c'est parce que on est
des dinosaures pas les dinosaures nous
emmerder il aimerait bien passer en
radio
la culture celle inverse la dépression
la dépression n'est plus petit qu on est
on sait pas comment on ira jusqu'au bout
du jour qui va sauver alors que la
culture des plus grands on peut être
plus divers on peut être plus beau à
part vous parce que vous êtes à des
sommets inégalés vers autrement pour le
président tunisien a décoré des
officiers de différentes unités
parmi eux mon chouchou il était un poil
stressé par la cérémonie assez mon tour
là c'est le grand jour faut pas que ma
foi
heil à la médaille à ces jeux suis décor
est allé je le salue et c'est terminé
hop